sie haben das ergebnis gesehen und
gehört
die anderen parteien haben in der
abstimmung heute unsere vizepräsident
die kandidatin nicht nur nicht gewählt
sondern sie hat noch weniger stimmen
gehabt dass das letzte mal das ist
sozusagen eine steigerung des
undemokratischen wenn eine solche
steigerung überhaupt noch möglich ist
es ist offensichtlich in diesem
parlament nicht möglich in irgendeiner
weise konsensual zu arbeiten sondern wir
sollen ausgegrenzt werden und man will
uns an nicht beteiligen an allen
demokratischen prozessen
denn es ist ja nicht nur der
bundestags-vizepräsident es sind ja auch
bestimmte gremien wir haben jetzt in der
fraktion darüber beraten
und wir werden jetzt künftig ich kann
auch nicht sagen jeder sitzung
wir fangen damit bei der nächsten
fraktionssitzung an
wir werden jetzt in jeder möglichkeit
die wir haben bei jeder möglichkeit
einen kandidaten einen weiteren
kandidaten für den vize präsidenten des
bundestages aufstellen und wir werden
zugleich prüfen lassen inwieweit dieses
unvollständig besetzte gremium zu
rechtlichen konsequenzen führt den in
dem präsidium werden ja wird ja auch
entschieden zum beispiel über beamten
beförderung und wir lassen prüfen ob
diese entscheidungen die alle ohne uns
stattfinden
legal und legitim sind das ist aber eine
juristische prüfung die bereits im gange
ist wenn wir da eine möglichkeit sehen
werden wir rechtliche schritte ergreifen
die andere maßnahme dass wir sozusagen
künftig jedes mal wenn es möglich ist
einen kandidaten für das amt des
vize-präsidenten aufstellen haben wir
heute in der fraktion einstimmig
beschlossen
ja eigentlich fällt einem zu diesem
vorgang der sich heute ab zum
wiederholten male im deutschen bundestag
abgespielt hat fehlen dafür die worte
uns wird das demokratische recht als
grösste oppositionspartei verweigert den
bundestagsvizepräsidenten zu stellen und
das ist etwas was ganz klar gesagt ein
schlag ins gesicht der demokratie in
diesem hause ist wir können überhaupt
nicht verstehen warum das so seit
anderthalb jahren gehandhabt wird und
wie er genannt dass jetzt gerade
angedeutet hat wir werden einen neuen
kandidaten bestimmen angefangen in der
nächsten fraktionssitzung
aber wir werden diese lage natürlich
sehr genau auch intern auch analysieren
wie es zu diesen ergebnissen kommen
konnte denn es ist eine tadellose
kandidatin gewesen es ist unser zweiter
kandidat gewesen für den bundestags
vizepräsident und unser erster kandidat
albrecht glaser auch ein tadelloser
demokrat wurde nicht gewählt und wir
hoffen dass durch die analyse und
letztendlich durch eine neuaufstellung
sich die anderen fraktionen das sehr
genau überlegen werden denn eins müssen
wir festhalten
die anderen fraktionen haben sich damit
keinen gefallen getan
danke so fragen sie einfach rausgehen
es ist unklug uns die sitze für wichtige
gremien vorzuenthalten
wir sind die größte oppositionspartei im
hause wir haben den vorsitz von drei
ausschüssen und selbst auch bei den
gremien wahlen den wichtigen gremien
fallen unsere kandidaten permanent durch
und das ist etwas was der wähler sehr
genau beobachten wird wie hier mit uns
auch umgegangen wird und dieses
verhalten deklarieren wir als ganz klar
undemokratisch und auch un- gemessen dem
wohnhaus gegenüber 7 von 10 11 euro
entschuldigung ich erlebe keine
freundlichkeit habe ich noch nie erlebt
deswegen ist das heute nur die
fortsetzung der bisherigen politik mit
ähnlichen mitteln aber vor der
wegscheide können ja gar nicht die rede
sein
wie sich jetzt ändern auf als reaktion
darauf
wir machen eine sachliche
oppositionspolitik im deutschen
bundestag und daran halten wir auch fest
die frage einmal sie haben wir gesagt
wer krieg haben wir kein krieg kriegen
in die ferne ist heute der tag dafür
gekommen und zweite frage es gab ja auch
meldungen kurz vor dieser wahl das in
den eigenen reihen es abweichler geben
wird die sie nicht mittragen könnten
vorher kühnel inwiefern wie sehen sie
das gab es diese abweichler und welche
auswirkungen hatte das das kann ich
nicht sagen
das glaube ich nicht in die fraktion hat
hier einstimmig votiert aber da keine
namen genannt sind
sind das alles vermutungen und ich
möchte zu vermutungen keine stellung
nehmen weil ich nicht beurteilen kann
es steht ja es ist angenehm und es steht
nichts dahinter das halte ich nicht für
eine gute journalistische tat muss ich
sagen
weltkrieg haben will kann krieg liegen
heute weltkrieg haben will kann krieg
für die machen das ja also die jungen
also ich bin ja wir sind ja gar nicht
die den krieg angefangen haben wenn das
heute keine weitere kriegserklärung auf
die vielen die wir schon hatten haben
dann weiß ich gar nicht was das ist ein
friedensangebot war das nicht oder
vielleicht der gasvertrag so ähnlich
haben das lokal
so werden auch zwei fragen 1 geht an
frau fiedler und dann an sie und dann
müssen die herren abgeordneten wieder in
bewegung bitte für die damen
wenn man zu hause bleiben können die
daten jetzt aufstellen werden bestimmt
die fraktion das haben wir heute nicht
gesprochen es macht mir der nächsten
fraktionssitzung